[Musica]
pomeriggio a tutti e grazie a mario
l'organizzazione di te da prodotti già
che questo invito per me un piacere un
onore soprattutto chiedo se possibile di
avere il minutaggio corretto quattro
minuti non ce la faccio a far la
presentazione e quindi ho lasciato un po
questo titolo perché non voglio svelarvi
l'argomento fino al momento opportuno
però voglio darvi qualche suggerimento
su quello che sarà un po il fil rouge di
questa di questa breve presentazione nel
cercare di mettere insieme aspetti
personali con quello che è il tema della
manifestazione quindi contaminazioni
ho guardato un po alla mia storia è
quello che so che ho fatto negli ultimi
anni soprattutto come detto punto mario
sono ingegnere e quindi sono persone
molto legate ai numeri sono persona che
guarda molto all'aspetto concreto ai
fatti alle evidenze non sono uno
scienziato come qualcuno prima di me mi
ha preceduto però sicuramente sono
abbastanza in linea con quel tipo di
pensiero sono storiche le conversazioni
con mia moglie
di fronte a quando si è dovuto
acquistare casa lei basava tutte quante
le scelte legate alla pancia io al
miglior amico che ci possa essere per un
ingegnere che un file di excel quindi
per darvi un'idea un po questo sono io
da questo punto di vista quindi dopo
quasi oltre 18 anni nel mondo della
tecnologia
penso di aver guidato un po di
background per spiegarvi perché credo in
quello che adesso vado a raccontarvi è
perché ritengo che effettivamente questo
sia un elemento che distingue le aziende
tecnologiche e le rende uniche
dopo 18 anni avendo lavorato prima e
microsoft e poi in facebook a quello che
ho osservato nel tempo e che ciò che
leggiamo spesso sui media e quello che
viene raccontato di queste aziende ossia
le loro competenze la tecnologia quelle
che sono i prodotti che vanno realizzare
sono luogo rossa il loro grosso asset in
realtà per quello che ho vissuto devo
dirvi che c'è un aspetto che è
totalmente imponderabile intangibile in
quello che loro fanno nel modo in cui
fanno quello che sono prodotti o
tecnologie
ed è qualcosa che accomuna un po tutte
le forze lavoro e per questo motivo
appunto voglio parlarvi di cultura
aziendale la cultura aziendale potrebbe
essere percepite come qualcosa di un pò
noioso un po magari poco poco
rappresentabile poco discutibile per vi
posso garantire che è un elemento che in
tutte le aziende tecnologiche quindi
dalla mia esperienza ma scopi cara
tantissime altre a google amazon a
twitter tutte queste aziende sono
veramente spinte da qualcosa che non è
legato alla tecnologia non è legato ai
loro prodotti chiave e nel cercare di
raccontarvi questo voglio un po farci
vivere quello che è la cultura che
altrettanto noi come italiani viviamo ea
farci un po prenderci un po consapevoli
di quello che la cultura sostanzialmente
porta ad essere la cultura certamente un
insieme di tanti elementi e sicuramente
apprendimento e di insegnamenti
sicuramente non è qualcosa che leggiamo
nei libri ma è qualcosa che viviano
qualcosa che prendiamo dall'esperienza
da quando siamo nati fino a i giorni che
stiamo vivendo quindi in questo senso mi
piace appunto facendo un po riferimento
a qualcosa dei nostri giorni fare
mostrare questa slide
insomma ci ha messo cinque minuti a
capire un po il significato di questa
slide però volevo da tifosi juventino
non appassionato in un fanatico sia
chiaro però mi piaceva questa slide a
perché da un po il carattere degli
italiani
la creatività il fatto di nel mondo
anche diciamo tradizionale essere
spiritosi divertenti e altrettanto
giocosi per certi versi questo è un po
il carattere dell'italiano magari simile
anche ad altre ad altre ad altre culture
ad altre ad altre nazioni però
certamente è un qualcosa che sul calcio
per esempio ci distinguiamo in tutto il
mondo sulla passione per lo sport e su
alcuni sport ha certamente non abbiamo
confronti dall'altra parte però circa un
anno fa
guardando la trasmissione in televisione
ho accolto ho sentito un passaggio che
veramente mi ha colpito è che un po
rappresenta altrettanto se pensiamo gli
aspetti culturali
quello che invece un freno abbiamo
sentito prima come ci sono dei freni per
l'italia da un punto di vista economico
ma altrettanto ci sono delle leve sulle
quali certamente l'italia gioca gioca
forse in attacco ecco voglio condividere
con voi un 40 secondi di un filmato di
giovanni veronesi a otto e mezzo che
raccontano sua esperienza e di come gli
italiani sono percepiti all'estero come
comunque questo effettivamente la
l'aspetto culturale ci porta molto
spesso a vedere tutto questo come un
freno ad esempio che una il timore via
il reddito di cittadinanza poi non so
sarebbe dato tre volte alla stessa
persona
e andato a girare al cuba e un militare
del governo cubano
mi ha detto che loro assegnano il wifi
gratuitamente alcune zone dell'avana a
caso io essendo italiano non ci ho
creduto ho detto mi dica la verità ci
sarà un inghippo sotto non ha detto nome
di lei è italiano e quindi lei è
corrotto di testa proprio perché noi
invece lo diamo a caso random non c'ho
creduto ancora oggi non ci credo perché
i salinari ecco questo filmato un po mi
ha colpito perché appunto
penso che molto spesso ci troviamo in
situazioni nelle quali il nostro primo
pensiero un po avere il sospetto non
credere nell'altro e comunque lo vedo
nel confronto per esempio con altre
nazioni a vendola la fortuna di poter
lavorare in ambienti multinazionali si
osservano questa differenza ecco volevo
portare questo che come esempio per far
capire quello che è la potenza della
cultura che noi abbiamo la cultura di
quelli che sono gli insegnamenti delle
esperienze che noi viviamo
quello che ha raccontato giovanni
veronesi è frutto non di quello che ha
letto dei libri ma quello che ha vissuto
a nel suo quotidiano ha vissuto dalla
sua infanzia fino ad oggi
ecco se pensate a tutto questo questi
elementi e come ci portano a prendere
certe decisioni
comprendete un po quello che è la
potenza di ciò che il concetto di
cultura bene nelle aziende nelle aziende
multinazionali credo che questo sia ben
rappresentato e non a caso a queste
queste aziende sono molto focalizzate a
fare in modo che ci sia una forte
coesione su alcuni principi su alcuni
valori è un qualche cosa condicio prima
di intangibile però certamente un
qualche cosa che aggrega e che crea
allineamento all'interno di quelli che
sono a quella che è la mission aziendale
va altrettanto quelli che sono alcuni
dei valori qua voglio un porto come come
esempi questa è la missione di amazon
quindi la cultura aziendale
stanzialmente a mio giudizio si unisce
tra un concetto di missione
quello che è un qualcosa di idealistico
sia chiaro questo è ciò che è stato
definito da jobs
n anni fa all'inizio della
dell'avventura che oggi sta avendo
successo che molti di voi conoscono
altrettanto però tutto questa come
vedete questa è la pagina web di amazon
che rappresenta un po alla missione ma
altrettanto leadership ensi polsa è
tutta una serie di altri elementi che
caratterizzano la vita all'interno di di
amazon a questi questi sono i valori di
facebook ossia quelli che sono i
principi attraverso i quali facebook a
cerca di operare ogni giorno e
attenzione non si applica soltanto al
mondo degli ingegneri si pensa che
magari questo possa essere applicato
soltanto a delle figure professionali si
applica un po in tutto il mondo anche in
un ufficio come quello di milano
piuttosto che di roma ossia tutta quanta
la forza lavoro allineati intorno a
questi valori e voglio raccontarvi tutto
questo con qualche esempio applicato
appunto alle varie aziende
questi sono appunto dei poster dei
poster che sono all'inter nel nostro
ufficio a quello che vedete a sinistra
per altro a cui il concetto di cultura
aziendale un qualche cosa non di statico
evolve a mou fastweb ratings era un
qualcosa che avevamo definito all'inizio
oggi è stato trasformato in muffa stand
bill things ossia cercare gli
altrettanto non andare contro le regole
e quindi cambiare scardinare un po
quelli che sono paradigmi noti ma
cercare altrettanto di costruire un top
a quello un paio di esempi in questo
senso e ripeto sono esempi che arrivano
gli stati uniti ma vi posso garantire
che anche all'interno di una country
come l'italia questi sono elementi che
caratterizzano il nostro quotidiano
quando facebook ha dovuto lanciare al
2008 le sue la sua versione localizzato
si era disponibile in inglese ma doveva
essere poi internazionalizzata quindi
resa disponibile nelle lingue ai tempi
nel 2008 c'era una qualche centinaio di
persone per all'interno di facebook come
forza lavoro ea per poter localizzare
quindi per poter tradurre scusate il
un sito fatto da oltre 300 parole in n
lingue seguendo principi tradizionali
ossia quella di prendere il sito e darlo
a quello che si chiama team di
localizzatori ossia di persone che
traducono fisicamente proprio quella
quella quel sito ha pensato a un modo
diverso proprio perché alle risorse per
fare quel tipo di lavoro non c'erano non
c'erano sufficienti risorse nel cercare
di fare questo è verrà intonata
controcorrente ha cercato di cambiare un
po i paradigmi cosa è stato fatto un
team di quattro persone gli ingegneri in
questo caso ha pensato ad un
applicazione che offerta ai consumatori
quindi agli utenti per mettersi a loro
di fornire suggerimenti su quelli che
potranno essere traduzioni e altrettanto
fare un voting system ossia ombre
permetterà ciascuna persona di dare un
giudizio tutto questo bene quattro
persone hanno permesso di tradurre un
sito completamente cosa che normalmente
avviene con qualche decina di persone è
stato tradotto non soltanto in una
lingua ma in 70 lingue prendendolo poi
anche un po divertente perché c'era
anche la lingua dei pirati per esempio
ma in questo senso volevo farvi proprio
l'esempio di 2008 quindi n anni fa
questo è quello che è stato fatto per
andare un po controcorrente cambiare le
regole sono slogan è vero ma vi posso
garantire che con n esempi ha trovato un
po tutto questo implementato proprio nel
nel quotidiano
amazon amazon è famoso per il tool pizza
stima che cosa vuol dire tu pizza stima
è un qualche cosa che per muoversi
velocemente a viene un po rappresentato
con un team non deve essere più grande
di un numero di persone che non mangiano
più di due pizze ok è un concetto un po
particolare però a vi dice quanto le
persone devono essere snelle quanti team
devono essere snelli per muoversi e
questo è un po nei loro prendiamo con
muffa st qualcuno lo rappresenta con tu
pizza stima però il modo di operare sta
veramente all'interno del del quotidiano
con alcuni principi cardine bio pena a
bio pen ha un qualche cosa che in
facebook è stato implementato con i data
center però voglio portarvi un altro
esempio di un'azienda che forse non è
considerata tecnologica per quello che
l'accezione che oggi molto spesso si
conosce quindi aziende che lavorano su
internet ma
lo rappresenta con tesla che un'azienda
che opera nel mondo automotive quindi
produce auto produce auto in un modo
anche lì e le vende in un modo molto
diverso rispetto al tradizionale però il
concetto di bio pen qua è molto ben
rappresentato se partiamo dal
presupposto che le aziende tradizionali
hanno all'interno dei loro asset cioè
delle loro di quelle che sono e quello
che il valore dell'azienda è una sorta
di vara somma di asset quindi di
competenze di brevetti piuttosto che
risorse bene all'interno di quello che
gli assedi un'azienda tuo motiva che
vive di che produce produce aziende
elettriche i brevetti sull'immagine
mento dell'elettricità è un asset
importante per tesla giugno 2014
i non masca ha sostanzialmente fatto un
po sta con quello come titolo ha ora o
patenza belong to you ossia tutto quello
che è un asset che viene valorizzato
all'interno di anche lì mercato
azionario se volete è stato reso
completamente accessibile a tutti che è
stato messo a disposizione di una
comunità con attenzione queste regole
viene messo a disposizione di chi poi a
sua volta nel prendere quel valore
contribuisce a crearne altro valore
quindi si cerca di sviluppare quel
concetto di apertura costruendo comunità
che a loro volta creano valore quindi
l'apertura bio pen che uno slogan se
volete guardarlo da uno sul dow da un
poster viene poi implementato
all'interno di tanti progetti in una
modalità che permette a tutte queste
aziende di scalare e ho preso appunto un
esempio di un'azienda che si è
innovativa e forse catena classificata
tra le aziende più innovative ma
certamente non ha a che fare soltanto
con un modo tecnologico
questo è un po il concetto di open
l'altro aspetto dell'ultimo col quale
conclude la mia presentazione è un po
legato al concetto di fallimento ed è un
po comune tutte queste aziende se stiamo
in italia la parola fallimento è un
qualcosa che si porta appresso un
elemento prevalentemente negativo è un
qualcosa che viene attribuito e viene
appiccicato alle persone ed è qualcosa
che peraltro non ti scrolli più di dosso
quando ti viene assegnato un concetto di
fallimento a te come persona
difficilmente poi ti viene rimosso theo
viene dimenticato in questa azienda il
concetto di fallimento è associato al
concetto invece di apprendimento
chiaramente fallire due volte a fallire
per due volte sullo stesso problema è un
problema ovviamente però fallire è la
ragione per la quale si crea innovazione
si abilitano le persone a prendersi dei
rischi se uno si prende dei rischi e sa
che rischiando può fallire il fallimento
accettato crea innovazione
in tutto questo voglio portarvi un
esempio di un filmato di voglio portarvi
un esempio con un filmato di quello che
è stato la creazione di un prodotto che
oggi spero molti di voi utilizzano che
sono i video all'interno di facebook
facebook ha lanciato i video n anni fa
ma attraverso un team fatto due persone
in un modello totalmente non strutturato
e con elevata probabilità di fallimento
è chiaramente ai tempi era anche leaked
all anno 2008 il prodotto era ancora
così piccolo che un fallimento non
avrebbe avuto un impatto elevato però vi
garantisco che non è 2008 anche nel 2018
questo tipo di principio esistono ancora
voglio farvi vedere questo video appunto
fatto di che racconta come due ragazzi
hanno realizzato un prodotto che il
prodotto video che oggi in chiaramente
molti di voi spero utilizzo interno dei
propri cellulari
weekend di spedirlo a vincere
[Musica]
bersani c'è del vero must di sante
scholes corpo ed espone i geni unici a
storia
bene questo è un filmato appunto diversi
anni fa che racconta appunto di come
sottosviluppato la parte video questi
due ragazzi sono sostanzialmente coloro
che l'hanno fatto accettare il
fallimento significa a segnala dei
ragazzi di 22 anni forse il secondo un
po più ad un po più grande però meno di
30 anni la possibilità di sviluppare un
prodotto che ha diciamo giocato
certamente un ruolo importante nelle
sorte di facebook a e nel suo sviluppo
quindi ho terminato volo raccontarvi
appunto questo ho voluto fare con
l'introduzione per dirvi come un
ingegnere che guarda sempre i numeri
ritiene che l'elemento vincente per
aziende tecnologiche sostanzialmente sia
qualcosa di intangibile e se andiamo a
guardare oggi grossi asset per facebook
sono certamente le persone la tecnologia
i dati prodotti questi non sarebbero
nulla se non aggregati e se non a coesi
all'interno di una cultura aziendale che
certamente mette insieme tutto questo
senza la cultura aziendale credo che
tutte queste aree tecnologiche non siano
dove sono e non portino quei risultati
che oggi riescono a mostrare a per il
consumatore e anche per tutta una serie
di altri soggetti che vivono sul mercato
con questo vi ringrazio
[Applauso]